paper plastic uh paper i guess yeah
trees right who needs them giving a
shade and life-giving oxygen
[__] them oh a plastic pen oh that's
good hi i'm philly oh what did i just
find on this oriental rug a space helmet
oh to the moon
you're not going to the moon you're dead
you put this on your head your
successful stand-up from the 80s
you get the reference yeah paper's fine
that's a good choice just don't leave it
next to an open flame or a radiator or
bam firetown usa population u maybe
you're the mayor i give the key to these
flames i'll just take this reusable bag
real manly choice
this will be a great place to keep your
roller blades elton